we're going to dive straight into our
main story tonight which concerns the
elections happening around the country
in two days there is the usual barrage
of negative campaign ads happening right
now perhaps none more memorable than
this one in a Pennsylvania da race
you've seen those motivational signs
people have in their offices Matt
Dugan's office had a sign too as
reported by a KDKA announcer it
reads the police
wow that is a striking ad now Dugan has
pushed back on that saying that's not
actually his office it belonged to a
different attorney but if so I now want
to know everything about them instead
because they have to be the only person
in the world who has a the police
sign next to a Bubblehead of what
appears to be James Madison not just
that that is next to a statue of Audrey
2 from Little Shop of Horrors which in
turn is next to a Bubblehead of Teddy
Roosevelt those are not usually shared
interests that fascinating individual
contains
multitudes but while some local races
are understandably focused on live laugh
the police office signage many
others will be focused on Reproductive
Rights abortion is a huge issue in the
Kentucky Governor's race and the race to
control Virginia State Senate and in
Ohio there's an amendment on the ballot
to enshrine the right to abortion in the
state constitution so tonight let's talk
about abortion as you know 16 months ago
the Supreme Court's dobs decision
overturned Ro v Wade and since then it
may have been tempting especially if you
live in a state unimpacted by the dobs
ruling to avoid watching The Fallout
from it too closely knowing how
depressing it would be and I'll be
honest things are Bleak but it's
important to understand exactly how
Bleak currently 14 states have enacted
near total abortion banss and two have
imposed six week limits and those banss
have prompted many to desperately try to
maintain abortion access for those who
need it and sometimes in truly
imaginative ways a California doctor is
proposing a floating abortion clinic as
a way to bypass laws in some states that
are restricting the procedure she says
the clinic would operate on a boat
floating in federal waterers just off
the Gulf of Mexico so technically making
it Out Of Reach to any state laws here
wow Lawless territory no rules anything
goes it's not only a foolproof plan it's
also the literal premise for the movie
money plane no you didn't hallucinate
that during Peak coid there really was a
film about a casino in the sky full of
Thieves cartels and arms dealers who can
never be arrested because the money
plane is always moving in international
airspace if you haven't seen it you
should frankly stop watching this show
right now and go watch that instead if
you pop an edible immediately it should
start to kick in right around when you
meet the film's villain Darius Emanuel
Grouch III AKA The Rumble played by
Kelsey gramar and he explains the money
plane like this whatever you want to
wager on the money plane has you covered
you want to bet on a dude an
alligator money plane yes yes
that movie is real it is the Frasier
reboot that we
deserved anyway back to abortion the
dobs decision caused immediate confusion
and panic especially in States that had
trigger laws already on the books which
kicked in almost immediately causing
chaos for both patients and abortion
provid us as soon as we heard the
decision we closed everything down
leaving over 70 women in Wisconsin with
appointments that we weren't able to do
for them I remember asking when is the
law going to change how much time do we
have to get ready for it and I started
to text back and say the law has
actually changed right now you know we
called patients it's like I'm already on
my
way and they thought well I'm already on
my way it'll be okay and it's like no
it's immediate it's immediate look
someone canceling plans when you're
already on your way is annoying in any
circumstance but it is different when
that plan is an abortion if dinner plans
fall through that is a bummer but at
least it won't end with something alien
out of your body unless that is you
reschedule that dinner to Long John
Silvers now thankfully abortion remains
legal in many states so at least
theoretically someone needing one can
travel to one of those States instead
but as this doctor points out in
practice that can be incredibly
difficult we have such inequality that
for some it's as easy as okay let's take
a weekend trip to Colorado to get your
abortion and for someone else it's a
completely life-altering thing that you
have no control over and you're forced
to give birth the trajectory of those
two people's lives are completely
different it's true for many traveling
across state lines isn't feasible even
before you consider that in states where
abortion remains legal it is not like
they've had a sudden surge in providers
to handle outof State patients so there
are now significant backlogs meaning
that women who travel to another state
may have more difficulty getting
appointments and it may even become hard
for those living in some states where it
remains legal which clearly isn't great
abortion isn't one of those things that
you can keep putting off indefinitely
like taking up Pottery or figuring out
who these guys are and why they're like
that I say this with zero malice by the
way they seem very wholesome I just
don't really understand what their whole
deal is I am going to get around to it
but to be honest
it's not a
priority and some are resorting to
drastic measures listen to this woman
who did manage to get a cross state
lines to New Mexico for an abortion
describe what's happened to her friends
who weren't able to what would you have
done if you couldn't come to New Mexico
for an abortion God who knows cuz I was
already asking people like hey what
could I do I've known some women to just
kind of take it into their own hands and
do like their own abortion like I had a
friend tell me she drank a cap of bleach
you know I had another woman tell me
girl like just take a whole bunch of
vitamin C listen there are a lot of very
good secret tips that women rightly
share with each other like bananas are
good for cramps or lipstick works as
blush in a pinch or block coach Brett
from your Instagram stories but drink
bleach or vitamin C to end a pregnancy
isn't one of them and unfortunately
dangerous measures like like those may
now become more common as anti-abortion
activists have no intention of stopping
their push for restrictions for example
they're also going after medication
abortions which are estimated to make up
half of all abortions a lawsuit to
revoke the fda's approval of myth of
prisone one of two key drugs in
medication abortions is currently
working its way through the courts and
if that were to succeed it wouldn't just
impact states with abortion bans it
would affect access across the entire
country so abortion La in America is
currently a complete cluster with
many confused and others considering
drinking bleach and yet the people who
wrote and passed these laws like this
Texas State Legislature will insist that
it's all worth it based on who precisely
and exclusively they protect thousands
and thousands and thousands of people
who would have chosen to have an
abortion now don't have that choice
that's right what do you say to those
people those are thousands and thousands
of little babies that are now alive we
are a very safe place for little babies
what a about women we are a very safe
space for little for women as well
oopsie you nearly said the quiet part
out loud there didn't you also it is a
pretty sad State of Affairs when but
what about women genuinely counts as a
gotcha question because For the record
abortion bands are objectively not safe
for women and can needlessly put them
through absolute hell take what happened
to this woman in Texas whose ultrasound
not only revealed no chance of survival
for the fetus but also potentially
life-threatening complic
for her Kay's doctor was clear when he's
born he's going to suffocate to death he
may live for a few minutes he may live
for an hour but he is going to die her
doctors said they could not perform an
abortion noting in her records
termination is not legal in the state of
Texas how could you be so cruel as to
pass a law that you know will hurt women
and that you know will cause babies to
be born in pain he was going to die a
painful death
so how is that Humane how is that saving
anybody they desperately want to have
another baby but there's a high
likelihood that something will go wrong
again the last time that I saw my OB she
said do not get pregnant in Texas right
now wow that is not only devastating it
is a truly horrible thing to have to add
to the list of things that pregnant
women are not safe to do so it's now
officially ride a roller coaster eat
sushi dye your roots and simply exist in
the state of Texas medical professionals
are now finding themselves caught in the
middle between trying to do what they
know is medically right for their
patients while also not running a foul
of the law or having their license
revoked one doctor said that her
colleagues were so unsure of whether or
not they could legally recommend their
patients seek abortions elsewhere that
they resorted to saying things like the
weather's really nice in New Mexico
right now you should check it out or
I've heard traveling to Colorado is
really nice this time of year which
isn't just absurd I'm not even sure
those are effective hints
New Mexico and Colorado are two of the
most objectively beautiful states in the
nation that could just be a nice
vacation tip now if the doctor were
recommending visiting Newark New Jersey
or saying I've heard Buffalo's nice this
time of year then sure you know
something else was clearly being
communicated and while you might think
that doctors facing emergency situations
should simply take it upon themselves to
quietly perform abortions anyway as this
OBGYN points out it's just not that
simple some people say well doctors
should just do it you should just go
take that patient to the O and do that
abortion I don't know of any doctor who
does an abortion just by themselves it
requires an anesthesia team a nursing
team supervising team to get you into
the O so in order for somebody to to
agree with me is I want to take that
patient to the O there's lots of other
people who are going to weigh into and
be scared and say no no we have to wait
for legal to sign off and that's when
people die holy we have to wait for
legal to sign off
is not something you want to hear before
receiving urgent medical care that is
something that we say when we want to
show this photo while saying the
sentenced sex crimes are bad or
playfully accuse a c Baron of being the
Zodiac Killer I shouldn't joke about
that though I'm sure Bob marray is
probably a lot more sympathetic to black
lung victims now that he is burning in
hell but but the larger Point remains
that even if you do have one doctor
willing to break the law and assume the
risks you still might not have a whole
team abortions are like improv everyone
involved has to be fully on board and if
just one person doesn't commit it's over
also even when it goes well you're like
okay that was fine can I go home now
please don't make me come back next week
and the crushing thing is that doctor
isn't even being overly cautious there
because while these laws do have
exceptions in instances where the life
of the mother is in danger there's a
huge difference between life of the
mother and health of the mother all of
these states have near total abortion
bans that do not make exceptions
considering the health of the mother but
even in states that do have those
exceptions they're often written so
vaguely or narrowly that doctors can be
unsure how to apply them take Texas
again where the health exceptions only
apply for a few highly specific
conditions so for everyone else doctors
now waiting until a patient is at actual
risk of imminent death to intervene
listen to this woman describe what she
went through after a fatal fetal
condition was diagnosed during her
pregnancy I had to wait until one of
three things happened either her heart
stopped beating I went into labor
naturally or I became so sick that my
life was in danger and at that point
because of the laws the doctors would be
able to induce me um and and we could
begin the delivery process I was first
diagnosed on Tuesday and it took until
Friday for one of those three things to
occur and for me what happened was I got
really really sick really really fast
obviously we live in the middle of Texas
which is a giant state so to get out of
Texas and to get to a neighboring state
where we could have gotten Healthcare we
would have either had to drive at least
8 hours or fly somewhere okay just so we
are all perfectly clear when we say that
these laws take away people's right to
control their own body this is what
we're talking about she had to wait from
Tuesday to Friday to get close enough to
dying to be saved preemptively choosing
to save her own life was illegal in her
State a state remember this man says is
safe for little sorry for women and when
you take all of this into account it is
no wonder that women in states with
abortion banss are nearly three times
more likely to die during pregnancy
child birth or soon after and this is
only exacerbated for people of color who
already faced significant disparities in
maternal and infant Health before the
dobs decision and at this point let's
talk about who is making these laws
because the rhetoric around the do's
decision was that it simply return
decisions on abortion to the state which
is a very nice way of saying it removed
decisions from individuals and their
doctors and placed them in the hands of
state legislators and those politicians
are now legislating medicine without
even a modicum of medical understanding
which is understandably incredibly
frustrating for people like this OBGYN
there's the feeling that your
expertise no one
cares no one cares went to school for 12
years of my life done this for 33 years
but but that guy from down south in
Oklahoma who's never picked up a medical
textbook in his life he knows all about
it I mean there's you definitely feel no
one cares what you think is an expert no
one cares right and honestly I would
give literally anything for legislators
in Oklahoma to have to explain their
reasoning to this Doctor Who Laughs like
a woman who has spent 45 years of her
life smiling on the outside and saying
go yourself on the inside which I
do realize sounds like the title of a
guides to being a woman in America and
it is not just that those pushing these
laws are non-experts they're also
overwhelmingly being pushed by people
who can't get pregnant either when it
comes to those so-called trigger laws
that banned abortion so quickly after
dobs 84% of the lawmakers who sponsored
them were men and look clearly they are
the the key problem here but let's also
take a second for the 16% of lawmakers
who were women because if you're a woman
voting against abortion access you are
and I'm told that this is the meanest
thing think that this voice is allowed
to say not a girl's
girl and some of those male legislators
truly did not know what they were doing
and that's by their own admission this
Idaho Republican voted for an extremely
restrictive abortion ban and has since
had second thoughts about how broad it
actually is but listen to him explain
just how little thought he put into his
original decision it really wasn't up
high on my radar other
than be I'm a pro-life guy and and I ran
that way um but I didn't see it as a had
a real having a real big Community
impact then he started talking with
local doctors what I'm wondering is for
you personally did you think about
abortion as it relates to obstetric care
for pregnant women no I I don't I don't
think
I I you know it's like anything you you
get exposed to something all of a sudden
you go wow there there's a different way
to look at this
H look part of me wants to welcome that
man's ability to recognize his own blind
spots there but are you really saying
that you didn't think about how your
vote would affect literally half of your
constituents you're a legislator
that's not a cute little oopsie it's not
like joking that Timothy shalamay could
play a Young Willie Wonker and the
studio immediately greenlit it and now
you have to figure out what the
that
means that is a dereliction of Duty so
what do we do now well first do feel
free to scream into a pillow uh when
you're on the bus on the kiss cam at a
basketball game there is no
inappropriate time to be screaming about
this but also know that we can still act
here some have taken some small steps in
the last year that are if nothing else
immensely satisfying like this one that
was covered by a Catholic News Network
an international group named after Satan
will soon open its first abortion
business in the United States the
satanic temple which claims to not
believe in a literal Satan will provide
Health screenings and prescribe abortion
pills for patients in New Mexico the
name of the soon to be facility the
Samuel Al's mom's satanic
abortion
incredible very well played now is that
going to fix everything no of course it
isn't but when it comes to responding to
such widespread Devastation you could do
a lot worse than the single best Your
mom joke of all time especially when you
add in that one of the group's
co-founders even said in 1950 Samuel
alito's mother did not have options and
look what happened but the most
important thing for you to do right now
is and I apologize in advance for even
saying this to vote abortion rights are
for all the attacks on them still widely
popular Six States have had abortion
related measures on the ballot since
dobs and in all six voters preserved
access to abortion and that was even
true in red States like Montana Kansas
and Kentucky the this is genuinely a
case where voting can have an immediate
and Lasting effect and to that end as I
mentioned there are some important
elections on Tuesday where it's going to
be crucial to continue that streak if
you live in Virginia Democrats lost the
house and Governor's seat in 2021 but
still control the state senate and only
because of that were they able earlier
this year to stop three bills that would
have restricted abortion but if they
lose the Senate next week that will
clearly change meanwhile in Kentucky the
incumbent Governor Andy Basher is being
challenged by conservative AG Daniel
Cameron who you might remember from his
disastrous handling of the Banna Taylor
case he has also said in a questionnaire
circulated by an anti-abortion group
that he support codifying personhood
from the moment of fertilization and
criminalizing providers who perform
abortions while all of that is obviously
terrible how exactly does he intend to
enforce life beginning at
fertilization does everyone now have to
in front of him no thank you very
much Daniel the only Kian who should
enjoy that privilege is the colonel and
no not that one I'm talking about the
Reber colel There You Go sir Madam NB
icon it would be an honor and a
privilege to fornicate in your presence
and finally if you live in Ohio a ballot
measure on Tuesday would enshrine a
right to abortion in your State's
Constitution it is a measure that is
currently being targeted by its
opponents in some wildly misleading
campaign ads the abortion industry's
proposed amendment would allow No Limit
abortions in
Ohio
abortions when the baby can feel pain
excruciating
pain on top of that the same radical
groups want to tear at the fabric that
holds our families
together allow our children to get
abortions without our consent and remove
all protections for The Unborn as
parents it's our worst nightmare wow
that ads argument is basically abortion
rights are an assault on the traditional
American Family a father a mother and
another mother who's 12 also if as a
parent your worst nightmare is your
child getting pregnant and not having to
stay that way if they don't want to I
don't know I guess we just have
different nightmares because there's an
objectively correct hierarchy of
Parental fears and it's one losing one
of your children two something terrible
happened to one of your children three
losing one of them but not in a dead way
in the oh I can't find them way and
then you have to decide whether to look
for them on your own or let someone know
immediately that they're missing because
if something's really wrong you are
going to need help but if they're just
kind of around looking for Lego sets you
don't want to announce to the target
employees that you're a negligent parent
who misplaced your child number four
your children hating you for exactly the
person you are that's not because of any
misunderstanding or anything your kids
know exactly what you're about and they
justifiably want nothing to do with you
and finally number five your child gets
really good at
swimming because that means you have to
take them to the pool by 500 a.m. every
other morning for 10 years a
child exercising bodily autonomy is
nowhere near a worst nightmare scenario
except for maybe the swimming thing look
this past year and a half has clearly
been devastating when it comes to
abortion rights and to be clear I'm not
just talking about the quote unintended
consequences around wanted pregnancies
I'm talking about the intended ones for
unwanted pregnancies too and abortion is
a medical decision between a patient and
their doctor full stop and it is
maddening to see some push to make their
states safe for little babies will also
making it far more dangerous for the
people they grow up to be but the Hope
here and there actually is some hope is
that as much as the needs lives and
choices of women have been dismissed is
also how much their anger and tenacity
has been underestimated you've seen
doctors and medical professionals
offering theirselves and services and
you've seen people like these bravely
and selflessly reliving private often
difficult moments to educate and
Galvanize others so many people have
been working tireless ly to make this
better and I wish they didn't have to I
wish they could devote their lives and
talents to something besides publicly
fighting for basic necessary health care
but they can't because this is an
emergency and one that requires action
from all of us and hopefully one day we
can eventually get to a place where
people who want to end a pregnancy save
their own life or make any other medical
or reproductive decision about their own
body will not have to seek out the same
legal loopholes that the money plane
provides for those who want to bet on a
dude an alligator in front of
Frasier